Arthur C. Clarke, author of "2001: A Space
Odyssey", once said: "Two possibilities exist:
Either we are alone in the
universe, or we are not. Both are equally terrifying."
Most media exploring the
topic of alien life in the universe
often work from the assumption that we
are not alone, and that our technology is
not sufficiently advanced to detect our
distant neighbors, or that they know
we're here and don't think we're worth
contacting, or any number of other explanations.
While these hypotheses may turn out to be true,
the other possibility that
doesn't get as much attention is that we
are, in fact, alone in the universe. If
that were the case, how would it change
our lives and our goals here on Earth?
For this thought experiment, we're going
to assume that humanity has a way to
accurately determine that we are the
only life forms in the universe, and work
from there. If one day, the news broke
that the universe is indeed a cold, dead
place, and that all life is contained
here on Earth, it would instantly bring
to mind two possibilities: Either we are
the very first life in the universe, or
the very last — and knowing humanity's
affinity for giant explosives, we could
very easily be the first AND last life
in the universe if we weren't careful.
Besides our new terrifying realization
that we are one planet away from a
completely sterile universe, what would
change? Let's start with the world's
space programs. If we were alone in the
universe, we could scrap any missions
designed to search for extraterrestrial
life. That would include numerous probes,
such as those intended for the icy
landscapes of Europa and Enceladus, as
well as entire branches of national
space programs like the SETI Institute.
We could use the money from those
programs to redouble our efforts in
preserving the earth and its natural
resources, or to fund new schools,
hospitals, or humanitarian organizations.
Of course, that's probably wishful
thinking, but the possibility is there.
If we wanted to keep that money in the
space programs, we could put it towards
research and development of ways to
ensure humanity's continued survival in
the event of disaster on Earth. Colonies
on the Moon, Venus, Mars, or even prototype
generational ships that could support
human colonies over several lifetimes
would be worthwhile endeavors. Of course,
with an announcement of such magnitude,
it would no doubt create polarized
groups within our global society.
As the only intelligent life in the universe,
would it be our responsibility to
seed life on other planets by sending probes
full of bacteria and simple organisms, or
are we no more than a blight on the
universe that should be contained to Earth?
Given our history of colonization
on Earth, it would stand to reason that
we would at least want to establish
colonies as far away from Earth as
possible, if only to ensure the survival
of our species in the event of a
gamma-ray burst or some other cataclysm.
But seeding life on other planets we'll
likely never visit would probably be met
with controversy. So far, we've been
working under the assumption that we are
the only life in the universe at all,
but what if we specified that we were the
only intelligent life? How would that
change the scenario? Well, if we assume
again that humanity has a way to
determine that there is no intelligent
life in the universe, then not much will
change initially. However, imagine a
scenario in which a probe from Earth
discovers single-celled life on another
planet, let's say Europa. In this scenario,
we would be the billions of years more
advanced alien species keeping an eye on
new life in the universe — something that
many people have suspected
extraterrestrials have been doing to us
over the history of life on Earth.
But what would we do about it?
To what extent would we interfere with
the growth of a new present in the
universe? Many would argue that the best
course of action would be to observe
from afar, and allow nature to run its
course no matter the outcome. Others
might want to watch, but take it one step
further, and intervene if the new life is
headed for catastrophe. Then, there will
most likely be a portion of society that
thinks we should physically visit Europa
and try to guide the life-forms to
success — a dangerous proposition, as
humans would carry microbes with them
that could endanger the very life we're
trying to protect. As one final
possibility, what if we were to discover
the presence of a very primitive species
just starting to use simple tools? This
would be the truest test of humanity's
disposition towards extraterrestrial life.
As with the previous scenario we
could look to the zoo hypothesis for one
example of how best to handle fledgling
life-forms. The zoo hypothesis suggests
that intelligent civilizations would
refrain from visiting planets with life,
to allow natural evolution and
socio-cultural development. It certainly
seems like the most respectful way to
handle the situation, and it's not too
much of a stretch of the imagination to
think that most world leaders could
agree to contact these extraterrestrials
only once they had reached a certain
technological or societal threshold. Of course, there would be others who
would want to visit them immediately, and,
I don't know, build pyramids or something...
While this may not seem like an
important topic to discuss, it allows us
to explore several interesting issues.
How would our space programs change if
we were the only life in the universe?
Would we scrap them entirely and just
focus on our existence here on earth, or
would we reallocate those funds to focus
on something more like an escape plan?
Would a newfound certainty of uniqueness
in the universe prompt us to become a
more peaceful species, or would life go
on the way it always has? If we
discovered we were not completely alone,
but at the top of the totem pole of
intelligence, would we act like the
curators of an intergalactic zoo? Would
we play the role of a benevolent god
race, intervening to prevent disaster,
guiding life towards civilization? Or
would we do the unthinkable, and ensure
that no life-forms ever become advanced
enough to threaten our position as the
apex predator of the cosmos? These are
only a handful of the questions this
topic can raise, and who knows if we'll
ever be able to answer them? Only time
will tell.
Leave your thoughts and opinions in the
comments below. Hopefully we can spark
some interesting conversations, and maybe
explore those ideas in future videos.
If you enjoyed this video, check out this
playlist of all my other space-related content.
Or, if you're really bored, you
can watch all my videos by clicking here.
Make sure to subscribe if you haven't
already, follow Second Thought on your
favorite social media, and leave a
comment down below with your opinions on
today's thought experiment. Thanks for
watching, and I'll see you in the next video.